écoutez si la performance que j'ai fait
qu'ils étaient destinés à une personne
au fait de la peine ou insulter les
familles qui sont endeuillées
je vous présente mes plus sincères
excuses faisait savoir que depuis un
mois de janvier je travaille jour et
nuit avec tout un réseau de santé
publique et un réseau de la santé avec
le gouvernement pour véritablement
vaincre ce virus dans le contexte de
cette situation l'homme à exprimer
énormément de choses positives et
d'amour je reçois des lettres
je reçois des cadeaux je reçois des
démos et j'essaie de répondre à tout le
monde je les fait je les fait autant
pour ceux qui mesurent que pour ceux qui
ont été gentils avec moi dans le
contexte de cette chanson qui avait été
composé dont je n'ai même pas entendu
les notablement les mots la personne qui
l'avait fait me demander si je pouvais
lui faire un petit retour je m'étais que
j'avais lui avaient dit oui je vais le
faire avec ma famille ce week-end on va
danser si j'aimais jouer à la maison
avec ma femme on va danser sur votre
musique
je peux plus y aller j'ai été pris à
québec par la suite ce que j'ai fait
c'est que j'ai il me relancer je les dis
bon ben coudon samedi matin je cite en
tee-shirt noir j'aime bien du chapeau
que tu es à la rentrée j'ai fait ce rap
j'ai dansé sur le roc 2 3 semaines et
donc la personne du mode pause quel sens
que c'est le bâtiment facebook j'ai
pensé que c'est un facebook un peu comme
moi j'ai un teint terne bon ensuite il
me posait une question c'est vers une
cause particulière que je défends dire
je trouve que la situation des
itinérants et des jeunes dans la rue et
des jeunes était effroyable que je
trouvais que si vous savez mais sans
penser une minute que ce serait une
collègue de ce sous financement avec ce
que j'ai vu père à terre les deux vidéos
quotas coupe donc moi je peux vous dire
que chaque nuit à 2 heures du matin je
regarde des décès et j'ai le coeur qui
me tourner
donc ça n'a jamais été mon intention de
blesser qui que ce soit et j'ai compris
que plus jamais je veux l'être aimé ou
sociaux par ce contexte là je vais
écrire bojan voulait renverser
et puis je vous remercie et je m'excuse
encore j'ai appelé la directrice du
refuge pour m'excuser de la situation et
je vous en remercie
ne pas dire merci pour la question